[Music]
I feel
good can't stop
loing I feel
nice when my heart stops
broking I won
stop till we got
something you going to see
when the be starts
[Music]
Jing
you just stand there close your eyes
please don't open
them don't open them don't open them
keep them
closed all right open
[Music]
them
[Applause]
baby you got me gu you got them boys on
pressure you like a movie I'm down to
love you forever Ain going to L You Got
Me Gucci Got Me Gucci worth it yeah
you're worth it do it for purpose do it
for and if you starting baby you
starting that we can work it that we can
work it
yeah we got some things we keep on a low
down and she really secret and love
songs got some plans with going lose I
can it it right oh yeah
this baby I Ain playing I ain't passing
I can take the pressure for the both
of you got me high high you got me high
high oh you show me love love love Love
Can't Get
Enough baby you got me gu you got them
pressure you like a movie I'm down to
love it forever Ain going to lose it you
got me Gucci Got Me
Gucci worth do it for purpose do it for
purpose and if youting baby that we can
work it we can work it we got some
things we keep on the low down and she
really like secret and love song got
some plans with going to lose I can it
right oh yeah this life on us baby I
ain't playing I ain't passing up I can
take the pressure for the both of
us you got me high
high you got me high
high you show me love love love love
Can't Get Enough no no baby you me you
got me guc you got voice on pressure you
like a movie I'm down to love you
forever Ain going to lose it you got me
Gucci you got me gu you got them Bo on
pressure you like movie I'm down to love
you forever ain't going to lose it you
got me Gucci Got Me Gucci worth it yeah
you're worth it do it for purpose do it
for purpose and if you sharting baby you
starting that we can work it we can work
it yeah we got some things we keep be on
a low down and she really like secret
and love song some plans with going lose
I
can oh
yeah baby I ain't playing I ain't
passing I can take the pressure for the
both of
us change you got me high high high you
got me high high you show me love love
love love Can't Get Enough no no baby
you me you me you got me
good pressure you like a movie I'm down
to love you forever ain't going to lose
it you got me
gu oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah yeah
happy do it purpose do purpose and if
you
baby we can work it that we can work oh
yeah this life on us baby I ain't
playing I ain't passing I can take the
pressure for the
B you got me high
high you got me high high you show me
love love love love Can't Get Enough no
no no
baby you me
you press you like movie I'm down to
love you forever a going to lose you got
me guci
me
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah purpose do and if you baby
we can work it we
[Music]
can hey it's been quite a while since
I've seen you smile or take time for
yourself or say it's good to be you been
soaking so long your head's hanging down
your face stuck in proud well listen
baby I'm done trying to keep it together
and wondering where I'm right or I'm
wrong now I need is a song Let's sing it
together for now or forever your baby is
out I got to be
free I got it be
free I I I I got to be free it feel so
good I got to be
free it feel so
good I got it
free I got it
[Music]
free
I I I got to be
free feel
good I got to be
free I feel so
good I I I I got be
good I got to be
free I feel so
good got to be
good I got to be
free I feel so
good got to be
free I feel so good I got to be
free I so
good I got to be
free that was so good I can't wait to
see
it how was that like
song Excuse me you guys have a moment
tell me what the film Project
possibly what do we actually do and what
do you need and so that's the thing you
don't know you just get in the circle
and then you wait to hear what it is do
you think it's going to be something
embarrassing um it's not I don't think
it's
embarrassing but also as soon as you
find out what it is you could decide not
to do it okay okay close your eyes okay
don't open
them wait let me see if she's ready
ready oh maybe face that way so you
don't see me coming yeah yeah yeah there
we
go all right so let me just put this
over you
we're just going to wait until it turns
green don't go yet don't go yet don't
want to get run over just pretend like
you don't even see me behind you okay
wait wait wait hey that's
[Music]
mine